You have approximately 171 billion brain cells
86 billion of these cells are nerves
Which processes the information, and the sense of different influences
And make you
What you are.
But there are things in our daily lives
Reduce this number?
What could kill your brain cells?
Previously, we had a belief that the brain could not
Produce new neurons.
Although neurons are a type of metastatic cell, this means they do not multiply.
We now know that new neurons are produced from nerve stem cells.
Throughout our lives.
But this is only done in certain areas of our brain.
In two small areas in the anterior brain.
So, while it can produce new neurons
The death of brain cells in large quantities may be dangerous and irreversible.
For example, within 5 minutes of a blow to the head
The axes compress and drive calcium to the nerve cells
Which can stimulate a number of different pathways and enzymes to initiate cell death.
This may explain confusion, loss of consciousness
And sensitivity to sound or light common in concussion of the brain.
Getting enough sleep?
Although the brain can adapt to lack of sleep in the short term
The 2014 study showed that waking up all night for many nights
May kill nerve cells in the blue position
This area of ​​the brain is responsible for coordination
Stimulate, maintain interest and excitement.
After long waking periods
We become unable to make important proteins to keep these neurons alive.
But do not be nervous about it, literally.
Long-term stress was associated
With damage to our Hossain area.
And reduced ability to make new neurons.
Which may explain why stress can result in many mental illnesses
Such as depression, anxiety, post-traumatic stress disorder, and schizophrenia.
Nicotine affects the hippocampus, too.
By cutting the creation of new neurons by 50%
While increasing cell death
Such as the smell of gasoline or permanent marker pens?
Although they do not cause direct damage to the brain
Some chemicals are stuffy
In the sense that it burns oxygen from the air you breathe
And deprive the vital tissues of it!
Eventually, brain cells are killed
Carbon dioxide, commonly released from stoves, furnaces,
Grills and cars, works the same way
By taking your hemoglobin
Which carries oxygen in the blood.
Cells in the main organs, such as the brain and heart
Will suffocate and die on a number of levels
What about alcohol?
It seems that exposure to alcohol in the short term
Do not kill brain cells!
However, communication can reduce them.
And over longer, chronic alcohol consumption
It can activate the immune cells in the brain to produce pro-inflammatory chemicals
Free radicals that can lead to cell death.
Alcohol addicts can also be affected by thiamine, vitamin B,
Which is called Fernik Korsakov syndrome
Which can kill brain cells and lead to memory problems
Loss of memory, and lack of muscular coordination.
Taking a break from drinking may be the best way
To promote the growth of nerve stem cells and other neurotransmitters.
But no matter how afraid of losing brain cells
We may not have a choice in this matter
Our brain volume decreases by 5% per weight per decade,
After the age of forty
With an increase of around 70.
The most common is memory loss
Which can be a natural part of aging.
In general, we should not be preoccupied with the number of brain cells we have lost today.
As losing it may be a sign that things are fine
During growth we produce more nerve cells than we need
Brain cells must die to keep the brain organized.
Research conducted on rats indicates
"We lose neurons in the frontal cortex of the brain.
As a way to reorganize our brain during and after puberty
More neurons do not make a person necessarily better or smarter.
Sometimes cell death leads to a healthy life.
Thank you so much for Science Sam for listing this video.
You need to follow them on instagram @ science.sam
It will inspire you with science and make you more interested in your mind
Do you know what does not kill the cells of your brain?
Podcast!
So you should listen to our blog
We just released our first direct podcast from Just For Laughs
We were very nervous, I think we succeeded.
Tell us what you think by using the #SidenotePodcast tag
We'll be waiting for you next week to watch a new science video.
Peace.
Translation: team translate @autrjim